i want to follow up a little bit about
the uh accused criminals
who participated in
rioting
destruction of property
sometimes violence against individuals
on january 6 2021 colloquially known as
the trump riots you know um the rioters
were overwhelmingly from a political
movement that claims to be about the
rule of law
and following the rules
and doing what the law prescribes
and yet
they broke the law
they broke the law
by trespassing they broke the law with
vandalism and uh entering
the
capitol building
they broke the law in some cases by
attacking police officers they broke the
law in some cases by stealing things
from the capital
some of them also destroyed the property
of media outlets outside the capital
they broke the law in many different
ways but
once you are accused of breaking the law
they believe in due process and of
course due process includes
both sides of it it includes due process
by those prosecuting you and law
enforcement but it also includes
facing the charges against you and
fighting them as you are able to do and
given a right to do with appropriate
counsel through the judicial system but
they're not all doing that either after
allegedly breaking the law on january 6
at least one individual
has fled the country and is now
desperately asking belarus an
authoritarian state at this point in its
own right
for asylum for cover in order to avoid
facing charges here in the united states
this is an extraordinary story
a guy named evan newman from california
has
started to
plead
with belarus on bella russian state tv
to let him avoid justice here in the
united states this is wild and we're
going to look at a video of this
evan newman is wanted in the u.s on six
criminal charges related to the
attempted insurrection on january 6th
including two felonies for assaulting an
officer now remember the right claims to
be about support the police law and
order due process so
guys accused of assaulting officers the
right should be saying oh this guy's got
to be held accountable
this guy is now trying to avoid even
facing justice wait that's not law and
order
he was featured in the bella russian
state tv special goodbye america
he recounted a treacherous journey
through forested borderlands that landed
him in minsk and expressed his
unwillingness to face justice in the us
newman says he's seeking political
asylum in belarus because the u.s in his
opinion is no longer a country of law
and order
think about that think about that for a
second they say they are about law and
order they then break the law
and say i'm going to flee justice
because my prosecution is no longer law
and order
what
this is another example of these are our
principles and they are so important
until they're no longer convenient for
us
check out this video this video is
from i believe i24 news
and this special where evan newman is
pleading for asylum in belarus to avoid
justice it's obviously not in english so
this is sort of like a dubbed
it'll give you a sense of what's going
on let's take a
for look critics the january 6 riot at
the us capital was already a propaganda
clue
casting the nation as chaotic and
violent
[Applause]
but the bizarre appearance of evan
newman an accused capital rioter from
california seeking asylum in belarus
right one of the world's most
authoritarian dictatorships was more
than the regime here could have hoped
for
speech
[Music]
this is their heavily promoted news
special dubbed goodbye america on
belarussian state tv
by the way
it's also funny how these very same law
and order people who broke the law
allegedly and then are fleeing justice
they also claim to be all about america
except they seem to not understand their
role in furthering anti-american
propaganda by showing up in belarus and
demanding asylum to avoid actually
facing justice in the united states the
us is now settling scores the anchor
says with opponents of the u.s
country or regime prison and torture for
simply taking part in protests she
falsely planned
newman himself being interviewed about
how he got here apparently by crossing
the border illegally through snake
infested swamps by the way
they also say you got to come in legally
but
he has abandoned that principle and
crossed into belarus illegally but says
it's justified because the law and order
charges against him he feels are bogus
and of course why he came
he speaks english but he's voiced over
in russian so it's hard to hear his
actual words they released
he says his photo was put on an fbi
wanted list that's true but his next
claim isn't what happened to other
people there
[Music]
what do you think they do with people
like me he asks they kept in solitary
confinement for eight months at a time
and beaten torture is a common thing he
explains to the bella russian reporter
torture is of course illegal in the
united states what is true is that
newman faces multiple criminal charges
in the u.s for his alleged role in the
january sixth insurrection prosecutors
say he taunted and screamed at police
before donning a gas mask and
threatening officers according to court
papers police body camera footage showed
newman pushing a metal barricade into a
police line before punching two officers
and we were invited to come in but we
were there because all right it's it's
just absolutely disgusting so listen
another one of these examples every
principle is abandoned immigration must
be legal
goes illegally to belarus
law and order must be followed
commits alleged crimes which are on
video on january 6th we must face
justice and due process and all of this
different stuff
flees as a fugitive to a different
country
all of these principles mean nothing to
them they mean nothing when the rubber
hits the road and this is just another
example
one of our sponsors is curiosity stream
the only subscription streaming service
that specializes in documentaries i
watch curiosity stream on my tv phone
and computer curiosity stream always has
so many titles i can't find on netflix
hulu or amazon
a much better selection of documentaries
than any of those platforms
documentaries on science nature history
politics tech music psychology i just
finished watching
man's first friend tremendous film about
dogs or dogs as some say if you love
documentaries and learning curiosity
stream is something you must have they
always have the newest most critically
acclaimed titles
and curiosity stream is giving my
audience that's you
25 off a subscription which comes out to
just 15 bucks a year go to
curiositystream.com pacman the link is
down below